НАТО готується відбивати ворожу атаку зі сходу.
Противник панує над частиною Німеччини й хоче захопити північний порт Росток.
Це легенда навчань Air Defender 2023 -
найбільших повітряних маневрів Альянсу з моменту його заснування.
Навчання відбуваються під проводом ФРН.
Я запропонував провести ці навчання ще у 2018 році,
після того, як заступив на посаду командувача ВПС Німеччини.
Це була моя реакція на те, що відбулося в Криму.
Коли Росія вдерлася в Крим, ми зрозуміли, що нам треба набагато більше
зосередитися на тому, як захистити Альянс.
25 держав, понад 10 тисяч військових, 250 літаків.
Сполучені Штати надсилають 100 повітряних суден, Німеччина - 70.
Швидка передислокація винищувачів, персоналу та палива через Атлантику - важлива частина маневрів.
Коли ми знаємо, що американські солдати можуть буквально за лічені дні передислокуватися сюди,
протягом 10 днів, це дає нам почуття безпеки, що при необхідності ми можемо себе захистити.
Відбиття атаки дронів і крилатих ракет. Захист міст, аеропортів та портів.
Евакуація мирних мешканців повітрям.
Усе це - сценарії, які прораховує і відпрацьовує НАТО під час навчань.
У ВПС Німеччини наголошують: маневри не спрямовані проти Росії.
Від польотів у бік Калінінграда організатори відмовилися, щоб не провокувати Москву.
Те, що ці навчання необхідні, стало набагато ясніше зараз, ніж коли вони тільки планувалися.
Після російського вторгнення в Україну ми знаємо, що європейська безпекова архітектура,
якою вона була протягом десятиліть, більше не працює.
І що обороні потрібно надавати набагато більшого значення.
Водночас, експерти зазначають: ідея стримування Росії читається між рядків.
Навчання, звісно, надсилають сигнал.
Вони чітко демонструють, що, хоча цей повітряний простір надзвичайно активно використовується
і зовсім невеликий за обсягом, ми готові захищати кожен сантиметр території НАТО.
Значна увага - до східного флангу НАТО.
Під час навчань винищувачі щодня літатимуть до Естонії та Румунії.
А відтак і до їхніх кордонів з Росією та Україною.
Повітряні сили США координуватимуться з європейськими системами озброєнь.
Німеччина, Іспанія та Великобританія надсилають винищувачі Eurofighter.
Греція, Туреччина та США надають F-16.
Угорщину представляють винищувачі Saab Gripen.
У південній Німеччині американські бомбардувальники А-10 розміщені поруч із найсучаснішим
у світі винищувачем F-35, оснащеним технологією "стелс", щоб приховати його від ворожих радарів.
Головна мета навчань: європейське небо має бути захищеним на всіх рівнях.
Протиповітряна оборона складається з кількох елементів.
З одного боку, це наземна протиповітряна оборона.
Вона складається з радіолокаційних станцій і зенітно-артилерійських та зенітно-ракетних засобів, які знаходяться на землі.
Але, звісно, маневри протиповітряної оборони також можуть відбуватися виключно в повітрі.
Наш літак може боротися з ворожими літаками.
Ми також можемо завдавати ударів з повітря по засобах противника, перш ніж він матиме шанс атакувати нас.
Ці параметри повинні поєднуватися.
Німеччина відіграє провідну роль у цих навчаннях.
Центр координації - авіабаза Вунсторф на заході Німеччини біля Ганновера.
Тут найбільший склад авіаційного палива в країні.
Але основна частина маневрів пройде на півночі ФРН.
У програмі Air Defender 2023 передбачене дозаправлення літаків у повітрі.
Так НАТО хоче показати, що може захищати європейське небо далеко за межами своєї наземної оборони.
Ми маємо певні діапазони, де можна розташувати або розгорнути наші ракети-перехоплювачі.
Це також дозволяє нам досягти підрозділів морської піхоти та військово-морських сил противника.
Тому що ворог також може атакувати нас не лише з суші.
Згідно з легендою навчань, противник також атакує з моря за допомогою військових кораблів і за підтримки винищувачів.
Поки в небі над Європою тривають навчання, цивільна авіація не зупиняється.
Попри те, що Німеччина - це один із найбільш завантажених повітряних просторів у світі.
Протягом десяти днів навчань по черзі, на кілька годин закриватимуться три льотні зони:
над північною Німеччиною і Північним морем, на сході й півдні країни.
Навчання - справжній виклик для німецьких авіадиспетчерів.
Цивільні та військові диспетчери повинні навчитися постійно координувати свої дії,
аби не скасовувати цивільні рейси.
Авіаційні експерти впевнені, що це цілком можливо.
У нас є три великі льотні зони на півночі, на сході й на півдні.
У той момент, коли вони активуються, всі цивільні повітряні судна повинні оминати ці зони
і перебувати в тісній взаємодії з потребами військових.
Це може спричинити затримки, так, але це зовсім не буде катастрофою.
Німецьке управління повітряним рухом прогнозує, що рейси можуть затримуватися. В середньому - на 5-10 хвилин.
При проведенні таких широкомасштабних навчань, як ці, над Європою, очевидно,
цивільні літаки повинні будуть дати дорогу військовим.
Хоча союзники по НАТО не хочуть зайвий раз дратувати Росію,
масштабні навчання все ж матимуть безпосередній ефект, певні аналітики.
Російська військова розвідка буде змушена відволікатися на вивчення авіаманеврів НАТО.
Саме в той час, коли українська армія переходить у наступ,
завдаючи дедалі більше ударів уздовж лінії фронту на сході та півдні країни.